[Music]
welcome to GameSpot's III 2018 stage I'm
Matt Padgett and today I'm here with
Vlad Mauer Hewlett's I hope I pronounced
your name right yes yeah that was
correct all right step one we've we've
got the names right now we're gonna go
on to the game what game are you playing
with or what game did you bring us today
well it will be a really really special
game it's it's actually a psychological
horror game it's it's about a boy named
actually Lloyd who is basically inside
of a dream and he learns to do crazy
things like he actually walks on walls
and ceilings and actually and stuff like
that and it's of course from dark I mean
the game is actually dark yeah all right
well let's let's take a look at this
wall walking yeah yeah yeah for sure and
okay I always do this alright so what
exactly do you do in this game actually
everything but I mean mainly I'm
actually the director and I also write
like pretty good the score for it as
well so here we see Lloyd and he's
inside of a train station right now and
he's inside of a dream and and that's
why he can do things like this so he can
walk on surfaces and in a second we'll
be entering a train here we are and here
we can choose an object but we don't
really have any so we'll just keep
moving forward and right now train will
start that's what it looks like we hear
an awesome sound there and we're ready
to move on to the next car and see
what's there so here we find a hole in
the floor and there's no way to go that
way but we can go on the wall and
actually go all the way around it and
hear Lloyd he sees basically a handle
that he can get that he can use on the
safe we saw right before then so we'll
just go there and
to use that so I actually the game looks
absolutely gorgeous what what exactly
inspired this art style oh well I'm
inspired I mean Ben melis actually
mainly I mean obviously you can burden
you can seal out of that influence and
I'm also inspired to my bite although
you know directors whom I liked a lot
but good Lynch you know Deltora and it's
also inspired to me by games as well you
know some of my favorites would be would
be limbo inside and actually a little
nightmares yeah you can definitely see
the influence with limbo inside little
nightmares I've got a question is it
I've also see a bit of like adventure
games maybe a little bit of games like
the old adventure games like flashback
and stuff like that where it's very
deliberate jumping you're you're solving
puzzles is is that what more of this
game is like or is it more of a
platformer oh it's not a platformer
actually we don't really have a like
basically jumping all the way down here
on this on this in this extra level um
so it's it's actually mainly about the
puzzles and actually with the stealth
because we see a lot of a lot of a lot
of you know weird creatures here in the
game as well so it has basically self
you know sequences yeah excellent yeah
I'm a huge stealth guy so is it all
about hiding and running away or do you
actually have to like fight these
creatures that he is he's actually weak
character he's really not into open
confrontation he has no chance against
all those creatures that we see actually
in a few minutes so you'll see basically
exactly how this works so we're in a in
a car here that we can open this door
and we found an object it's sort of an
oversized corkscrew that we'll use a
little later on we can also see a stage
here but we can't really use anything
here that actually works so we just keep
moving forward here yeah here we find
the engine which is basically the main
element of the level we can't really do
anything with it yet so we'll just keep
moving and see what awaits us here and
so here we have an example of actually a
puzzle that we see a lot of those
basically in dark as you can see them in
the lever is actually not active so we
need to make sure that it gets
electricity so first we need to make
sure this is you know fixed and now we
can solve this
since here I've done this actually
hundreds and hundreds of times so I'm
just really gonna do it you know fast so
I can show you the rest of the level it
actually takes a little longer usually
just solve this but yeah he can open the
door now and he finds a chess here and
and instead of a chest he gets he
actually gets a toy it's yeah since
actually I'm a musician I love basically
those additional elements you know that
actually relate to music you know so
here I'm gonna show you an example of
actually using the object in in a very
me way because it's sort of it's sort of
illogical you know he has a toy but he
can turn it into into a real you know
think here and using the lever he can't
make a hole in the wall and now we were
actually really into a creepy no dreamy
environment he's actually inside of a
moving train but he's also in a cave and
in the cave he he will see a creepy lady
there so it's as you can see it's really
not basically a logical environment it's
really really dreamy and weird
so here need to make sure I stay quiet
because if I make a lot of noise this
will happen so there is no joking around
with her so this time I'll try to sneak
and actually make sure that she can't
hear us because she's actually actually
guarding a dynamite and there that we'll
try to steal from her everything around
her it's it's yeah she she looks like a
difficult landlord lady probably so yeah
I need to really watch out on my way out
as well because she can still get me so
I need to stop when she starts you know
being agitated like this and and we
slowly move out of this area to the next
area
it's okay I can I can actually run now
so I was wondering there was a portal
there how complicated do the puzzles get
because there's definitely like the the
thing that really sends out to me is the
adventure game elements of like you put
this piano there and it's not
immediately clear what you do with that
piano yeah I think I think at birth the
fun of the game is that you're in the
dream world so you really don't know
what to like actually expect because in
this in this kind of reality anything
can happen at any time so it's very the
fun just actually learning what's what's
not gonna happen next all the puzzles
are challenging what we see right now
it's actually not the beginning of the
game it's actually the middle of the
game so it's a little bit you know
challenging it starts it starts it's
it's a little bit easier at the very
beginning of the game do you how varied
are the environments because we see a
train we saw a cave I'm guessing there
there are a few more dreamlike yes there
are a lot of a lot of you know different
environments in the game there is a good
I like I like actually a city there's a
subway station and there is a house like
a castle sort of thing so it's it's
actually really worried really varied
yes so right now we need to create so he
know he finds the wall there right and
we'll try to blow it up and as you can
see we have a pretty unusual puzzle here
because we need to connect basically the
cables with his own hands which is
really really painful you're not
supposed to do that I mean don't try
that at home by the way thank you I
definitely I may I may have tried it at
home for sure so yeah so when exactly is
this coming out and what platforms will
I be able to play it on well I'm hoping
to finish the game by the end of this
year and at first it will be only
available on active Windows but I'm also
hoping to make like basically ports next
year in consoles so we'll see we'll see
how it goes let's exit well hey thank
you so much for Adam super-great you
very much dark with you sure that's da
RQ exactly with the cube yep
and I'm super excited to play for myself
thanks again and have a rest fantastic
rest of you oh thank you so much I
appreciate it
great thank you